[Music]
choreographing the last two dances
the last two that we've got so intense
and there's so much dancing in it and
he's doing such a good job he would
never been able to do that week one so
I'm just that just proves to me just how
amazing you've become like he's a he's a
dancer he hats off Rashad Jennings and
Emma Slater prepping for the Dancing
with the Stars finale I mean I think
every single rehearsal has been pretty
pretty pretty full-on because she
doesn't play any game she's like a
perfectionist over and over and over and
over again it's crazy but I love it it's
funny like I feel like I've known him
for years I would be so stressed
throughout all my seasons but now he's
like he's like just sunshine like he
doesn't stress and and when I'm like
going crazy thinking of steps he goes
down and a big smile and then all of a
sudden like the answer like you don't
need to stress like it just is the worst
so I got to say I think that the secret
is just it's him
I mean I'm she deserves it like
seriously I don't want to let her down I
can't explain how much she's helped me
we truly have each other's back and when
we on the dance floor it's just us
[Music]